foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
compared chocolate to Chocolate compare
fruit to fruit yeah M M's has the candy
coated chocolate Market by far M M's Tic
Tacs olives and category
let's learn more together than anything
else little [ __ ] color bead things so
you could eat those all together in your
mouth candy necklaces where do you put
that in do you wear that with Eminem's
too candy necklaces parties Smarties is
here Skittles down here today Smarties
what about Sweet Tarts what about Pez
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah where do you
put Pez dude oh dude like
[Laughter]
an elevator up there huh just to have a
piss oh my gosh so um there's actually a
lawsuit that is uh coming out against
Skittles good claiming that the candy is
just handsome she has a big Pez head
over here claiming that the candy is
quote unfit for human consumption wow
dude I'll eat that [ __ ]
you telling me Marshawn Lynch made his
whole [ __ ] career eating Skittles
look at him he's fine perfect health why
why is it just like it's just a [ __ ]
ball of sugar so the uh parent company
titanium in it or some [ __ ] bars
Incorporated they're being sued for the
use of titanium dioxide how did you
[ __ ] know that I just read about it
because I'm a huge Skittles fan he keeps
up to date because I was like
titanium it's in the coloring I think
yeah titanium dioxide or chemically a
tio2 is found in Skittles uh that just
sounds wrong like we shouldn't eat
medals like that yeah make sure it makes
your teeth white for human consumption
um consumer geneal Thames filed the
lawsuit in Oakland California on
Thursday claiming in court documents
obtained by news that candy contains
quote heightened levels of titanium
dioxide tio2 pretty much they was there
was no comment from Mars Incorporated uh
a further research shows that they had
mentioned phasing out and committing to
phasing out tio2 and its product
um back in February 2016.
but has failed to do so as of now still
so the lawsuit is so that that substance
is that's FDA approved
so that is I think Up For Debate because
uh they had mentioned that everything
that they had done had fallen had fallen
into strict FDA regulation codes but I
believe that because like new things
continue to like be discovered through
science and the consumption and health
and stuff like that
um different tier markers for where like
the amount of like a certain type of
ingredient can be allowed are they
actually breaking the law by having it
on there it's dosage dependent I'm sure
that what else is that product
Reese's Pieces never did [ __ ] like that
they might they have the colored this
guy's gone against Reese's just a just a
backup Skittles apparently from what I
read it's it's like vibrancy in the
color yeah and dude Reese's Pieces very
vibrant
you guys remember
um yellow five it's like don't yeah
don't [ __ ] do it it's not new I
didn't drink Mountain Dew for years what
are the drawbacks of eating Skittles so
well titanium dioxide right specifically
titanium dioxide dioxide is a natural
metal element that's also used as a
white pigment in a variety of other
products such as sunscreens Cosmetics
paint primer come on we put that on our
body all the time the pigment grade is
also known as titanium white or pigment
white six and is the widest and
brightest of all known pigment that
sounds crazy I want my Skittles to be
bright nah you gotta take the white down
food what foods contain diet titanium
dioxide generally foods that commonly
contain titanium dioxide include heavily
processed items in these categories
candies and sweets including Skittles as
well as Starbursts Jello and Sour Patch
Kids dudes everyone tells you not to eat
that [ __ ] anyway okay I don't know what
side of the table you're wrong
oh [ __ ] you're right you're right cake
decorations under Mars as well uh
chewing gum uh chocolate which ones
which ones just says chocolate it says
milk products pastries salad dressing
and sausage you don't know what's
chocolate it could be [ __ ] it could
be Andes mints it's [ __ ] Mars Bars
dude let me see which chocolates
patties dude see
that's what I'm saying man do you guys
have a favorite candy like of all time
yeah Bart why don't you go once you take
this one titanium just
give me give it to me straight
my number one favorite is Reese's Peanut
Butter Cups really those are really good
those are good mine hits me on the mood
bro depending on the mood that I'm in I
like my peanut butter cups in the fridge
that is good have you had the thin ones
I like those the thin ones in the fridge
do you like that you like the bigger
ones or the have you tried have you
tried the potato chip one what what
that's peanut butter cup potato chip one
that they sell in the store it's not
potato it's it's inside the peanut
butter cup whoa a chip is inside the cup
yeah they put it inside the Peter it
comes with it so you buy the peanut
butter cup with potato chips also it's
mainly for a texture it's mainly for
Texas
yeah dude that's money a little salty in
there like rice crispy type like
chocolate bars or the crispy ones or
like even Twix I love cookie inside of
like chocolate caramel I remember the
first time I ever had a um like a
chocolate covered pretzels it [ __ ]
blew my mind yeah
the same combination right yeah even
Reese's put [ __ ] uh pretzels in their
[ __ ] too yeah pretzels and titanium what
are some side effects from eating
Skittles that you're okay with
like farting it sounds like this article
hasn't presented any wrongdoing of
Skittles to me so far it sounds pretty
deadly yeah it's like it's like dude
look you die from Skittles you're a
[ __ ] if it increased what if it
increased cancer risk by like 0.01 then
do other [ __ ] to decrease that cancer
really it's a lifestyle right it's like
bro obviously you're not gonna have
Skittles every [ __ ] day and you're
not eating them all [ __ ] day some
people are yeah and that's that's all
you they tell you not to do that right
well you tell you not to do what's worse
eating one Skittle a day or having a
whole bag once in a while One A Day what
a day all right you're good you're good
so you got 365 Skittles a year it's just
one a day you die from that oh bro you
deserve to be gone when they were they
were asking Papa John like they were
like you realize that one pizza has like
a thousand thousands of calories and he
goes yeah don't eat the whole thing like
slice
dude but that's what that's the argument
right like because are you eating the
whole pizza bro obviously obviously eat
your fruits and vegetables you know what
I mean yeah and then every now and then
you can indulge in Skittles I don't see
what the argument is like we all know
that this is bad for you not bad for you
but like you can't eat it all the time
he made that report like he feels so
dumb because he's like he's like dude I
don't even eat the whole thing and
honestly there's only what like 300
calories in a slice you know so like
share it with someone yeah share it he
eats Skittles right what's up Reese's
Pieces
was the ET I'm sure E.T would have loved
Skittles I'm sure
throw them in the trash they'll put them
on the line yeah make one big ball and
then I drink water and you have Skittles
juice fast wow
that's what activates the titanium maybe
that's why I'm done the biggest thing to
activate titanium is water
yeah dude I'm still a team Skittle yeah
class action lawsuit followed by a
California resident alleges anyone
consumer Skittles are at a heightened
risk of a host of health effects for
which they were unaware stemming from
genotoxicity the ability of a chemical
substance to change DNA oh my God
so you can get away with crimes yeah
yeah
so you don't want to father a child
anymore you just need a bunch of
Skittles go ahead fingerprint this cup
so that means if she wins we might all
get like a 30 Cent check
we're not
we're like 16 seconds all the time I'm
on record saying I eat Skittles I
deserve a little cash this comes after
Mars Incorporated allegedly vowed to
phase out titanium dioxide from his
products in early 2016 and promised to
comply with France's ban on the use of
the chemical in 2019 so France started
that oh so in Europe they already dude
France started it
we're gonna listen to those guys we're
Americans we don't listen to French
people you know
[Laughter]
let's put more titanium in that [ __ ]
yeah that's American we gotta be
Americans about it right not only
titanium gold let's sound [ __ ] silver
let's have [ __ ] aluminum for [ __ ]
no reason they couldn't find anything
else to put in the Skittles besides this
titanium [ __ ] okay skills are not the
only sweet treat under speculation right
the environmental working group found
titanium dioxide in more than 3 000
other Ultra processed foods 3
000. and this one hurts me more
Hostess Donuts that's my [ __ ] [ __ ]
all these boots is that what makes the
whiteness yeah is it the is it the
powder is it the chalk just says Hostess
Donuts donuts I love those those are
good those are good both the white
powder and the crumb the chocolate can
[ __ ] the best oh I ate the chocolate for
you
get the varieties Donuts too I like to
make donut juice out of those
that sounds [ __ ] disgusting
just lit up
but this is why they tell you not to
consume too much heavily processed foods
what's too much for someone else though
just just have like one snack a day you
don't have to like that's a lot you
could you could have a half a pack of
Skittles a day like we're adults come on
stop eating all according to the update
this is where it gets [ __ ] up
according to the FDA the FDA is
responsible for regulating all color
additives to ensure that foods
containing color additives are safe to
eat contain only approved ingredients
and are accurately labeled however when
determining the regulatory status of a
food ingredient the FDA says it's the
responsibility of the manufacturer to
ensure all the ingredients comply with
regulations so I have no idea what that
means so that means the FDA don't know
they're like so that's like pretty much
me like it's it's our job to do this but
it's your job to do that and it's your
job to make sure that we're doing our
job
don't put too much of this in there you
know just a little bit
once it's nice and vibrant stop pouring
the bag
[Music]